mais délibérément christine paris avec
vous nous restons sous le signe du
charme et de vos football aux françaises
qui a rencontré norvégienne oui qui ont
été battus 3 0 est mersin bell où elles
sont elles et puis moi je voudrais vous
un peu remonté ce soir je voudrais qu'on
arrête cette misogynie
parce que c'est complètement ridicule on
veut faire de la femme sportive un sex
symbol
on veut des catherine deneuve des bo
derek et d ursula andress sûr pour le
terrain du monde a lancé comme l'indiqué
vous en avez non mais on a nous les
femmes et un certain sport qu'on
apprécie pas on le dit pas
l'haltérophilie je veux pas faire de
peine à pierrefeu la halle et au chili
les boxeurs au visage tuméfié
les rugbymans match alors pour pouvoir
nous pourquoi ne pas laisser je voulais
confondez mais pourquoi mais non parce
que les footballeuses ont beaucoup après
les journalistes et je croyais au quand
même et finalement elles sont terrorisés
elles ont elles ne veulent plus voir de
journalistes elles sont complétées brisé
et vous allez le voir beaucoup plus
parlé dans les vestiaires
non sérieux nous voulons bien voir les
footballeuses même quand elles voudront
venir c'est que ces relations d'amitié
au nom du tchèque symbole allez-y
mesdemoiselles ne voir trop grand
bientôt
[Musique]